first and foremost the number one thing
as you think about how you're spending
your money to make more money aka
marketing
you have to take your personal opinions
off the table
the number one reason so many people
struggle is because they say dumb [ __ ]
like
well i don't like tick tock who gives a
[ __ ] carl do you like money
the biggest vulnerability in this room
is not being smart enough or being
hungry enough it's just actually not
knowing how to dominate when it comes to
people relationships
you know i think i think
most people that would be in a room like
this if you're here you're doing [ __ ]
let there be no confusion if you're here
you're doing [ __ ] right you know for
especially for somebody if you're 24
hours into feeling like oh carl's really
crushing it or susan's doing it if you
feel any level of like that you're
completely confused because if you're
here you're doing it right
the question is how big is doing it and
what do you actually want and i think
the
thing that i would really try to land
first before i go into other subject
matters is
you'd be stunned how much your personal
upside is being capped if you aren't
profoundly kind to the people that work
for you
it is a very
grandma statement
it's a very kind of like
kind of like the world is kind [ __ ]
but it is profoundly impactful and so
i would bet the farm
that many dozens of people in here are
dicks
to their team
i would bet the farm on it it is just
the way the business world is it's the
way society is and i i beg
for the people in here as i'm going on
this subject matter
if it gives you any thoughts or feelings
if you want it for you
for you
i promise you
that what's happening underneath you and
how you're setting the tone and what
you're doing is a huge impact on your
zeros
this is not about entitlement and
letting people get lazy and like silly
non-results things this is about
building empires this is about building
big empires but you would be stunned i
believe
and the reason this is an important
subject matter is i'm sure at this point
plenty of people have heard about the
great resignation right because of kobit
the thing that i'm way more worried
about as all of you go on your journey
to build the things that you want to
build
is the great never applying in the first
place
the amount of options
17 19 22 year olds have going into the
world and they're aware of it of how
easy that will be the word i use it is
to make 60 000 a year flipping on ebay
making content on tick tock
dabbling in nft land there are so many
more options than what we grew up with
if you're over
35 here that it's profound and people
are missing what's actually happening
and this is an absolute subject matter
that i hope you take very seriously if
you are not focused
on retention
people actually wanting to stay
if you are not focused on retention
first
you will lose and when i say lose you'll
still win
but you'll lose upside that you can't
even see
so it's incredibly important since we
have time together on this day that we
nail this subject matter which is
first and foremost the number one thing
as you think about how you're spending
your money to make more money aka
marketing
you have to take your personal opinions
off the table the number one reason so
many people struggle is because they say
dumb [ __ ] like
well i don't like tick tock who gives a
[ __ ] carl do you like money
this is the profoundly most
fundamentally silly thing that i hear
every day of my life gary i don't get
youtube
but trillions of people do
i don't like it
you probably don't like a lot of things
you do every day if you're here you know
my favorite thing about a group here is
is that you eat a lot of [ __ ] every day
to make it happen there's plenty of
things you don't like
this is not about what you like or what
your opinion is of a platform or you
don't like technology
i mean some people try to go so lofty
with me gary i'm not doing it because
it's bad for the kids
right like or or they go political it's
like looking for any excuse not to put
in the work to something they don't
understand yet
and so for me
when i look at the landscape of what's
happening in the world
the speed in which attention is shifting
is profound
facebook and and and google
twitter and youtube
tick tock these things are moving so
fast you know it you know tick tock came
out of nowhere for most of you in the
last 24 months elon bought twitter
yesterday this stuff is just moving it's
moving and it's moving fast and you have
to understand that even more importantly
than balancing your checkbook
is your ability to understand where your
customers attention is and how to make
pictures videos the written word audio
to get in front of them and do business
and
for a lot of people that are winning
the quickest way they lose market share
is by being outflanked by competitors
doing contemporary work when they got
cozy because they were winning this
today is about business
you can do it however you want to do it
when i start this conversation with the
first 10 minutes around culture and how
you treat people
i'm not joking about what i said i know
a lot of people struggle with that here
they don't they don't work hard enough
to your standards they shouldn't
they don't make as much money as you do
like if you like people you know how do
i get my employees to work as hard as me
i'm like help them start their own
business
i appreciate that these are the
important conversations
because when you win this when you
figure out how to build an actual team
you can scale
i could do a lot of things but you can
only do so much
so many of you are carrying way too much
stuff because you're not building teams
you're a micro manager you're insecure
you're not building up retention you
can't create scale it's only people
it's people
and so that's a huge combo and then the
second part and then
that is i think we should get up here
and do some q a the second part is
something we really need to spend time
on while i'm still here if you do not
have a contemporary marketing plan you
are losing market share you are losing
growth if you don't have people around
you that want to be there and you're
constantly having to retrain and find
different people you're losing growth
the blueprint's simple the execution's
hard so why don't we do a bunch of q a
around that i'm really really happy to
be here thanks for having me
so what drives you
a level of gratitude and guilt that i
have such a natural talent to
communicate and execute that i can have
a profound impact and i feel a sense of
obligation
to kind of leave it on the field it's
not wasted yeah it's kind of a curiosity
of like how good can i do it
you know
like it's like
what when you know again for the people
that raise their hands and for the
people that don't know me well like my
big thesis is you have to cut out the
noise all of it
especially the positive noise
when everybody tells you you're great
and you're awesome you become addicted
to that now you're completely vulnerable
to the negativity the reason i'm so out
there on social is because it's hard to
be so out there and social
most people can't deal with the heat
they don't like when somebody says
they're ugly or stupid or full of [ __ ]
or a scam artist or they suck or they're
overrated
people don't like that i don't care not
because i'm so cool it's because that
person doesn't know me
how can i possibly be upset when
sallypants47 is having a bad day
is having a bad day and decides to take
it out on me because i look too happy i
meant but i'm not mad at hate i'm
compassionate to hate
but at the same token
knock on wood for me 90 of my comments
are just little goat emojis
and that and that and that requires
and that requires even more tune out
because when you get high in your own
supply it's a wrap so i know that you're
i know i've heard you talk a lot about
well like you said from you know
switching it you know when you said i
was thinking of my mom because she was
in school and they said oh we're going
to email and she's like why the heck
will you use email i can just walk down
to the other classroom and just you know
give you know teacher so-and-so a
message i know i've heard you see people
do you know do you know i apologize do
you know that when canvas came out all
the artists said that wasn't real art
that if you didn't put it on buildings
it wasn't real art
you should go read what they said about
the television
like we always demonize new technology
humans are incredible
at romanticizing yesterday and
demonizing today
so i get it good so i know you're
bullish on tick-tock
what do you what are you most bullish on
in terms of if someone had to pick one
form of communication marketing channel
etc this is why q a is so fun because
it's a game of self-awareness if for
example if you're incredibly insecure of
your visual exp appearance
you can't do video
it's a it's a mental block
right so now you might have to do audio
which all of a sudden becomes should you
do twitter and do audio posts and post
there right like
for example i am even though i'm a five
or six time new york times best-selling
author i can't put two sentences
together
i like i that's why i have to record all
my books everyone i love when people
come to my when i do books and i have
book settings man the book sounds just
like you and i'm always laughing i'm
like because i [ __ ] recorded it
and somebody put it into a sentence form
you know um
you know so for me
i i'm not gonna go to linkedin and write
four paragraphs over you know while i
have a cigar or a glass of wine or or on
the tread like we're walking you know
but for me as many of you know video
comes very natural so i think first
you have to know yourself of what format
allows you to communicate for a lot of
people here being an independent little
a little scary maybe having a sidekick
or a friend now all of a sudden you got
a podcast
right so you have to know yourself first
after that to be very frank if you
actually know how they all work
they can all be great you can dominate
on twitter you can dominate on you can
dominate maybe you're a great host or
hostness all of a sudden maybe it's a
facebook group that you should be
building right so there's a lot of ways
to win
now there are always moments of time
where there's so much attention on a
platform that if you post you get more
organic reach without paying everybody
always gets mad at the algorithms that's
just supply and demand you weren't there
early enough
instagram [ __ ] me it's free
thinking like a billion dms from
influencers gary instagram [ __ ] me i'm
like it was free you made millions it
was free
so
the algorithm doesn't change not because
you're a conservative it's because
they're running a [ __ ] business and
more content means less and less
consumption means supply and demand more
more kids went from instagram to
tick-tock more people are posting to
instagram than they did two years ago
what the thing what do you think is
gonna happen of course your video is not
gonna get a hundred thousand views
anymore it's gonna have forty thousand
it's called supply and demand of
attention
that's what i trade that has been the
foundation of my career i had email
newsletter in the 90s that had 95 open
rates i bought every wine term in the
world on google adwords the day google
adwords started i started a youtube show
long form was one of the first five
humans on earth to do it i was one of
the first 30 people to have a million
followers on twitter like this is my
career
and so i understand it and so the answer
is figure out your form of communication
if you're capable of doing tick tock you
go all in and tick tock is not you know
three years ago i'm like tick tock tick
tock tick tock and everyone's like it's
14 year old girls dancing i'm like for
now
facebook used to be just college kids
now it's just grandmas
it changes
[ __ ] changes it evolves and so you're on
facebook quite a bit no worries me too
listen
i just got done saying it's my favorite
platform right now because
like no emotion complete detachment
like complete detachment
it's just whatever the market wants
and so many people make judgments
subjectively in their mind about things
and it's a mistake this is very
important you have to ask yourself what
your relationship is with money
it's imperative
so much of my luck
is because i don't like it enough
all my friends are like
you know
all my friends have like i have so many
friends that have moved to puerto rico
and miami and texas it's like [ __ ]
out of control right and they love to
like razz me they're like you're in
[ __ ] you know like you're not only
are you in new york you're in new york
city you're paying city tax like they'll
go on a whole 13 [ __ ] and i make real
money that's real money and and they'll
like go on a 13-minute [ __ ] rant and
then i'm like
i don't care
and they're just like baffled
i'm like i like new york
i i need the action i don't want to
[ __ ] live in l.a in l.a or miami or
puerto rico or [ __ ] ecuador i want to
live in [ __ ] manhattan
and so like but for other people they
love money and guess what
zero judgment
who the [ __ ] am i [ __ ] me i don't care
if
if if they want to if they want to move
from la to [ __ ] austin texas knock
yourself out if you want to move from
[ __ ] connecticut to [ __ ] the
outskirts of miami have a [ __ ] ball
the thing that i love is my mom has no
idea who gary is
i have some real hopes and dreams
i actually have no expectations of
anybody or anything which is why i'm
always happy but i have real
expectations about heaven
i've got some big hopes and dreams for
heaven there's two core things i'm
really hoping about heaven one
that everyone's there and i can have
some real some real talks i got a lot of
questions from the people that are not
around anymore
and two which is really cool i think
you'll like this
i think that heaven
has
some weird version of google
where this is like i dream about this
where you go up there and you can type
in anything and heaven will show you
what would have happened for example
first thing i'm doing when i get to
heaven first first query
heaven
show me
the time i came closest to dying without
knowing it enter
and i have these two core scenarios one
if i would have eaten that peanut i
would have choked on it and died or two
my favorite one the time i forgot my
keys
in the house ran out forgot ran back in
and grabbed them but had i grabbed them
i would have got hit by a bus and died
so i've got big hopes for heaven
i'm gonna be super pissed if it's not
there
and so uh i'm excited about that
question if someone that you see people
that they buy the shoes the watches the
starbucks but they're not willing to
invest in themselves and they say think
oh my gosh poor what was me how do you
get people to shift from the consumption
to investing in themselves i have so
many friends that like nice things they
always get mad at me because i put out a
lot of content about this and i don't do
a good enough job so i'm gonna try to be
better about it
the reason i talk about buying things is
because
if you really know if like you grew up
for 25 years 40 years like reading car
books and going to it and it was your
grandfather saying look like it makes
all the sense in the world when you get
to financial memes that you want a
lamborghini what i'm worried about no
different than buying an nft or anything
else are the people who are buying it to
disguise the actual truth
they're using it as a proxy for their
insecurity it's how i'm gonna get the
girl because i'm insecure it's how i'm
people going to think i'm successful
because they don't it's all that stuff i
get worried about that because i know
that's not a sustainable model for
happiness and i talk about that
you know
investing in yourself comes in a lot of
forms
you know
it's one thing to say don't buy a
starbucks for eight bucks or don't buy a
lamborghini or rolex and put it into
a content a mastermind like things to
better yourself
my personal belief is better yourself is
a simple game of this
i actually think
most people need to downsize and
simplify at scale
maybe not as crazy as what your parents
did but
but that was an extreme version that
actually has a ton of merit well they
left l.a yeah it it it
it was
think about the time we were in in
america that led to a lot of that kind
of behavior and i actually think there's
a lot of truth in it like it's so funny
because i because i'm so into business
i'm into all this other stuff that i
love
so it's not obvious what's actually
happening in my wiring but i just want
more simplicity for people the more
simplicity you have and and for me
simplicity comes in the form of judgment
the thing that i'm trying to think as
much about as possible is how do i
have a conversation that might impact
someone positively about the concept of
judgment and it actually starts with
yourself
the thing that i'm really hot on right
now is of course so many people are
judging each other they start with
themselves
i just wish people wouldn't beat
themselves up so much like i hate when
people are like oh but gary you don't
get it on me i'm just i'm so ambitious
i'm like i'm the [ __ ] craziest
ambitious person i've ever met my life
that doesn't mean that if i don't win
this year or this decade that i think
i'm a piece of [ __ ] that's not healthy
and i definitely don't have envy envy is
a framework of conversation that has to
be eliminated how can you envy someone
when you don't know them
you know a piece of them
you know a headline of them you might
like something that's going on with them
how can you actually envy somebody that
you know nothing about we just have to
simplify
simplify
but
like for me it's so simple to be content
and hungry as [ __ ] at the same time
i've come to know that that's confusing
and sounds like a contradiction but i
have to continue to unpack it because in
that
is [ __ ] everything it's the whole
game when you like want it more like i
want to be the greatest human that ever
lived
i genuinely swear on my children's
health as i sit in front of you here
right now that when i die in 55 years
when i'm in heaven doing my google [ __ ]
i'm gonna look down and i'm like okay
good seven billion people came to my
funeral that's how i wake up every day
trying to navigate my life
at the same token
if it all ended tomorrow and nine people
came that's fine too and finding that
balance of extremities to make it
balance not like something that's
confusing is something we have to talk
more about and so to answer your
question in a very long-winded way
what i would say to that person is
break it down get simpler
tune out the noise
most of all tune out your own noise
against yourself
everybody else is gonna have judgment on
you you need to be your number one
[ __ ] fan for real not kidding and i
will remind you
no matter who the [ __ ] you look up to
they suck at a lot of things too
thank you let's give it up
[Music]
you